well uh ukrainians are not losing it and
with the support they've had from the
West they will not lose it the question
is can ukrainians win the Russians are
not going to win but can the ukrainians
win and if so when and of course I think
we all recognize and particularly having
listened to recently to president
zielinski that
um until they get all the Weaponry that
they're asking for metal tanks
self-propelled artillery and the like
um they won't be able to mount a proper
counter-offensive and crack the Russians
so long answer I'm afraid K to a short
question ukrainians will not lose this
the Russians cannot win it what we have
to do is help the ukrainians to win on
the battlefield
bring other pieces into this chess game
don't we we bring in China we bring in
Belarus we bring in Iran and we bring in
what's happening in moldovan airspace
what impact is that going to have
well these are all wider considerations
as you quite correctly point out
um yes I think the other thing of course
is interesting is the attack on the
Russian spy plane in in Belarus that's
an indication of the lack of support the
lack of universal support that Putin and
Russia has in the region and then of
course is there is the wider question of
what support more widely in the world we
see many African nations sitting on the
fence we see China making a very
interesting contribution to all this
um giving moral support but until now
not giving physical support as far as we
can determine and India being pretty
pretty wary in its in its relationship
uh and lack of warm support for Russia
so Putin I think we have to infer is
feeling more and more isolated and
undoubtedly under huge pressure himself
uh yeah but lots of those armies or
military that are hoping to help Ukraine
are also um struggling some might say
even our own defense secretary says that
our military and our defense budget has
been hollowed out
well well you're right but of course
these um he's related but these are
separate issues
um and it comes to the live issue in
this country about whether Ben Wallace
will be successful in persuading Jeremy
Hunt to give him an uplift in the
defense budget he's making the case for
somewhere between 8 and 13 billion
pounds extra personally I think that
case is very strong uh and in a sense as
the next former Army Chief I would say
this again that's a part of that
additional money if he's able to get it
must go to our land forces not just to
increase our own capability but to make
up very rapidly for the arms and
Munitions that we have given to the
ukrainians and we are being too slow I
think to let contracts to Industry to
replenish our stocks and continue to
make such stocks available to the
ukrainians it's one thing saying that we
support them it's another thing to make
sure they don't lose but we absolutely
have to take the opportunity of giving
them the opportunity to mount
counter-offensive in the late spring
early summer so that they can win this
war and defeat the Russians on the
battlefield that must be must be the
objective yeah let's throw another
country into the mix should we Saudi
Arabia our president zielinski met with
the Saudi foreign minister recently
um how do they fit into the mix
well they are an important third party
country as far as all this is concerned
um I mean I think
we would like to expect that Saudi
Arabia will want to support Ukraine I
think Saudi Arabia would probably see
that in the round its best interests are
to support the west and there's a
developing relationship between Saudi
Arabia and America it's been a complex
relationship up to now but I think the
Saudi rulers are probably coming to the
conclusion that taking everything in the
round it's better to side with Ukraine
supported by the West than to hedge its
best Hedges Bets with Russia
okay unfortunately we are out of time
but fascinating stuff as always my Lord
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you